we begin in China where president Xi
Jinping is hosting the leaders of five
essential Asian Nations the summit
coincides with the G7 meeting of
advanced economies being held in Japan
let's go live to Jessica Washington for
us now initial and then Jessica a
meeting to discuss big trade issues but
also full of symbolism here
that's exactly right this is a very
significant Summit not only for China
but for the Central Asian Nations as
well as you noted that symbolism the
fact that we're here in Xian is deeply
important this was the historical
capital of China but also the starting
point for the historical trade routes
that went through Central Asia the Silk
Road but as we're here in Incheon we
know that China is really amping up this
diplomatic Focus trying to engage
Central Asian Nations and for the
Central Asian Nations themselves well
this is an opportunity to diversify
economic prospects for many of them and
for the region as a whole China is
already the largest trading partner and
they will be looking to expand upon
opportunities perhaps various Visa
initiatives trade initiatives it's worth
noting this in the broader context the
war in Ukraine of course has had a
significant economic impact and for
these countries what they're looking for
is opportunities outside Moscow as
Moscow pours funds into its war in
Ukraine and also faces the economic
impact of sanctions as well some of the
bilateral meetings taking place on the
sidelines of these Summits has have
already taken place we know that
President Xi Jinping just his First
Financial meeting was with the Kazakh
president kasim Jomar takayas and a
short while ago he met with his
counterpart from Kyrgyzstan who is Sadia
japorov and we saw a statement from the
Ministry of Foreign Affairs noting that
they talked about opportunities for
shared economic Prosperity as you noted
this Summit this week takes place at the
same time as the G7 Summit takes place
in Japan we already know that the
leaders of G7 Nations will be looking to
take a hard look at China we know that
some issues are likely to come up issues
of Taiwan the South China Sea and what
the U.S calls beijing's economic
coercion on the rest of the world so as
we look to anticipate that the G7 will
take a rather critical approach of
Beijing Beijing is surrounding itself
with like-minded and friendly countries
this is its own answer to Summit
diplomacy
Justice live for us there thank you